O
RECOVER FROM NEARLY TWO MONTHS
SINCE RUSSIAN FORCES LEFT THE
AREA.
>> TERRIBLE.
ALL RIGHT.
MELISSA BELL, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
JOINING ME TO FURTHER DISCUSS
THE SITUATION IN UKRAINE, FORMER
U.S. DEFENSE SECRETARY WILLIAM
COHEN.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, SECRETARY.
SO LET ME GET YOUR RESPONSE.
SPEAKING YESTERDAY ON UKRAINIAN
TELEVISION TO MARK HIS THIRD
ANNIVERSARY AS PRESIDENT,
ZELENSKYY VOWED UKRAINE WILL
BATTLE TO A BLOODY VICTORY, BUT
INSIST THE RUSSIAN INVASION WILL
STILL END WITH ZPLOEM SI.
AND EVEN WITH WHAT MELISSA JUST
DESCRIBED FOR US, THAT MARIUPOL
IS LIKE A ONE-WAY TICKET INTO
THE CITY, THE KIND OF CONTROL
THAT RUSSIA NOW HAS OVER
MARIUPOL, DO YOU SHARE
ZELENSKYY'S VIEW THAT AFTER ALL
OF THIS, DIPLOMACY WILL HELP END
THIS WAR?
>> WELL, MOST WARS ULTIMATELY
END IN DIPLOMACY THAT ONCE IT'S
DETERMINED ON THE BATTLEFIELD,
WHETHER THERE IS A WINNER AND A
LOSER, THEN THE DIPLOMATS TRY TO
RESOLVE WHAT RESULT CAN WE
PRESENT THAT BOTH SIDES CAN LIVE
WITH.
I THINK PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY SAID
NUMBER ONE, I WANT TO DEFEAT THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY AND DRIVE THEM
OUT OF UKRAINE.
THAT'S OPTION NUMBER ONE.
THE SECOND OPTION WOULD BE I
WANT TO DRIVE RUSSIANS MOSTLY
OUT OF UKRAINE, BUT THERE MAY BE
SOME AREAS I'M WILLING TO GIVE
UP UNDER CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES.
NUMBER THREE, WE HAVEN'T
FOCUSSED ON IT UNTIL JUST NOW
WHEN YOU BROUGHT IT UP.
ODESA.
THE BLACK SEA.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A WORLD
FAMINE ON OUR HANDS UNLESS
THERE'S SOME WAY TO REACH SOME
KIND OF AGREEMENT FOR THE FOOD
THAT HAS TO BE HARVESTED THIS
SUMMER AND FALL INTO THE HANDS
OF WORLD COMMUNITY.
SO THERE ARE A NUMBER OF OPTIONS
THAT OUGHT TO BE ON THE ABLE,
AND CERTAINLY THE UKRAINIANS
HAVE TO SIT DOWN AND THINK ABOUT
THIS AS DO ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE SUPPORTING UKRAINE.
WHAT -- IF WE GO THROUGH DRIVING
THE RUSSIANS OUT OF UKRAINE,
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN IN TERMS OF
THE OPTION OF THE ARMY BEING
ABLE TO BE PUSHED ALL THE WAY
BACK INTO RUSSIA ITSELF?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN IN TERMS OF
GETTING FOOD OUT OF UKRAINE?
WHAT DOES IT MEAN IN TERMS OF
GETTING MEDICINE IN?
YOU HAVE ALL THESE ISSUES THAT
HAVE TO BE PUT ON THE TABLE IN
THE PLANNING PART OF IT.
AND I THINK UKRAINE OBVIOUSLY
HAS TO LOOK AT THOSE DIFFERENT
OPTIONS, EVEN THOUGH HE'S
SAYING, I'M GOING TO DRIVE THE
RUSSIANS OUT.
I WANT EVERY INCH OF MY
TERRITORY BACK, BUT I'M WILLING
TO NEGOTIATE AT THE VERY END.
YOU HAVE TO GO THROUGH AND LOOK
AT THE OPTIONS.
ONE, TWO, AND THREE, AND SEE THE
UP SIDES AND DOWN SIDES.
>> AND ARE YOU SUGGESTING THAT
PART OF THAT NEGOTIATION IS
GIVING UP SOME LAND TO RUSSIA?
BECAUSE THAT'S ALL RUSSIA WANTS.
>> I CAN'T -- NONE OF US CAN
MAKE THAT RECOMMENDATION.
ONLY PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY CAN
LOOK TO HIS PEOPLE, LOOK TO HIS
SOLDIERS AND SAY HOW MUCH ARE WE
WILLING TO CONTINUE THIS ON?
CAN WE CONTINUE THIS FOR A LONG,
LONG TIME?
AND THE QUESTION BECOMES WILL
THE UKRAINIAN ALLIES BE
SUPPORTIVE OVER THE LONG TERM?
YOU CAN HAVE DIVISIONS START IN
EUROPE.
THE UNITED STATES.
YOU HAVE MEMBERS OF THE
POLITICAL PARTIES HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES WHO SUPPORT PUTIN.
WE SUPPORT RUSSIA.
SO THOSE ARE ISSUES THAT
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY AND THE
EUROPEANS AND THE AMERICANS HAVE
TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT, HOW LONG
CAN THIS GO ON?
I THINK PUTIN HAS ALWAYS
CALCULATED HE CAN WITHSTAND THE
SANCTIONS LONGER THAN WE CAN
IMPOSE THEM.
BECAUSE WE ARE A DEMOCRACY AND
HE'S OBVIOUSLY IN A
DICTATORSHIP.
THOSE ARE ISSUES THAT OBVIOUSLY
HAVE TO BE PONDERED.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, IT'S HARD TO BELIEF.
IT WAS THREE MONTHS AGO WHEN
RUSSIAN OFFICIALS PREDICTED A
QUICK AND DECISIVE VICTORY FOR
MOSCOW.
IT'S REPORTED THEY ARE PLANNING
TO RESUSCITATE THE SPUTTERING --
SPLITTING OFFENSIVE IN UKRAINE
FIRING COMMANDERS, SPLITTING
COMBAT UNITS INTO SMALLER
FORMATIONS.
WHAT DOES THIS TELL YOU ABOUT
THEIR CALCULUS OF THEIR
INVASION?
>> NUMBER ONE, THEY MADE A
STRATEGIC MISTAKE.
TWO, THEIR GENERALS HAVE NOT
BEEN WELL PREPARED FOR THIS WAR,
NOR WERE THE CON SPRINTS AND
THOSE IN THE ARMY WELL TRAINED
TO CARRY OUT THE MISSION.
THE MISSION WAS THE WRONG ONE IN
THE BEGINNING.
AND THE TACTICS WERE WRONG.
SO NOW THEY'RE ADMITTING THAT,
BUT REMEMBER, IT WAS NAPOLEON
AFTER WATERLOO, THE FIRST THING
HE SAID WAS IT WAS THE GENERALS
WHO LOST THE WAR, NOT NAPOLEON.
I THINK YOU'RE SEEING THAT WITH
PUTIN SAYING FIRE THE GENERALS,
AND APPARENTLY HE'S GETTING MORE
INVOLVED IN THE TACTICAL
DECISIONS.
I THINK IT'S PROBABLY A BIG
MISTAKE.
HE'S NOT A TRAINED MILITARY MAN.
FOR HIM TO GET INTO THE DETAILS
AND TRYING TO ORCHESTRATE ALL OF
THE MOVES THAT TAKE PLACE ON THE
GROUND, IT REMINDS ME OF ONE OF
THE ADS WHERE A PERSON UNDERWENT
BRAIN SURGERY AND THE PATIENT
ASKED THE DOCTOR ARE YOU
QUALIFIED FOR THIS?
AND HE SAID NO, BUT I DID STAY
AT A HOLIDAY INN.
IT'S THAT KIND OF I THINK
SITUATION WHERE PUTIN AS A
STRATEGIST, TACTICIAN, ON THE
GROUND FOR THE MILITARY, I THINK
IT WOULD BE A BIG MISTAKE ON HIS
PART, BUT THAT WORKS TO THE
ADVANTAGE OF UKRAINE AND THOSE
OF US SUPPORTING UKRAINIANS.
>> YEAH.
AS FUNNY AS THAPAR LEL I